they abused their Authority they abused
the trust that the American people would
have in that Authority I I I just think
it's a very dangerous situation where
you have this this guy who has to be
compromised considering all the pies
that his family was in and all the
millions of dollars that flowed through
to his son and his brother and various
other family members you know how can
Joe Biden not be
compromised
[Music]
hello everyone watching and
listening today I'm discussing something
truly explosive I would say with
columnist and writer Miranda Divine
we're talking about her 2021 book which
should be old news by now but hasn't
been well covered enough to be that
laptop from Hell Hunter Biden big Tech
and the Dirty Secrets the president
tried to hide we delve into what Hunter
Biden inadvertently unconsciously or
purposefully revealed about his family's
business dealings how they built and
maintained the regime The Surreal but
comprehensive coverup by the so-called
deep State enforced and willing
collusion with the Legacy and social
media companies and the aftermath yeah
we're not done with that yet not just
for those directly involved not just
American citizens but for innocent
people all across the world find
themselves in the midst of political
psychological and physical
Warfare it's quite the episode I thought
maybe we'd open up with actually the
story of the laptop itself because and
we might want to what might as well walk
through this in chronological order and
so Hunter brought three laptops as I
understand it into this laptop shop do
you want to pick the story up there and
we'll wander right through to the point
where the New York Post is publishing it
and then it's the story isn't covered we
can set the stage for everyone just so
they remember exactly what's going on so
do you want to walk us through that
story sure um so it's April 2019 and
late uh at night uh Hunter Biden goes
into John Paul ma Isaac's little
computer repair shop in Wilmington and
Hunt has been at a cigar shop nearby he
smells of booze um and initially John
Paul MAAC didn't recognize him he just
felt a bit of irritation that someone
was coming in with three water logged La
laptops right on closing time um and uh
he booked them in and um Qui pretty
quickly ascertained he couldn't um
immediately fix uh any of them and uh
then um Hunter signed a work order and
gave his contact
details and went away and um the next uh
day or two um jum for ma ISAC is looking
at three laptops he's figured out one of
them he can just give him a new keyboard
separate keyboard and that will work and
he figured out something with another
one of them and the third one he decided
he would have to upload the contents
onto his um big server and then um uh
you know give the contents to uh Hunter
on a on a hard drive he called Hunter
and he said can you come in and uh bring
in um he told him particularly what the
hard drive was he wanted and sure enough
the next day Hunter brings the hard
drive that he'd asked him to bring and
um John Paul ma Isaac gives him the
other two laptops one is a Rite off one
he's given him a keyboard with it um and
uh and then Hunter goes away and jumo
Mac ISAC continues to um it's a very
slow process he said to upload all this
information because the um the battery
kept on running out on the laptop so he
had to keep on charging it and then
restart and every time he restarted he
would have to look on at the material to
see where he was up to and that was why
he sort of had such a a kind of intimate
understanding what was on the laptop and
um you know what initially struck him
was just there was so much porn on the
laptop that's so I mean it's home made
porn it's um it's Hunter uh filming
himself having sex with various women um
filming himself naked and so on but jumo
Ma ISAC also noticed um you know a lot
of business documents invoices and a
company called barisma which uh popped
up a lot so um he completed his work and
he called Hunter to come pick up his
laptop and got no response he was
texting him and emailing him and he
wanted hunter to pick up his property
and to also pay his $85 bill um and that
didn't happen and so 90 days later as
per the work order um H the property
became his uh he he owned it now and uh
he just put it on a shelf and didn't
think about it anymore um and then um so
we're talking about April 2019 and
Hunter dropped off this lap top just
about a week before his father announced
that he would be a candidate for
president and uh Hunter at the time was
in a rage against his family absolutely
furious with them at the end of his
tether he felt that um Joe's staff that
he'd amassed in his campaign were
disrespecting him and his father was
allowing uh them to disrespect him um
and uh you know there were Stories being
brief to Friendly media that Hunter is a
basket case he's a drug addict um you
know he's just a bird and his father has
to put up with and as far as Hunter was
concerned how dare they uh treat him
like this um and and shame him when uh
he felt that he'd um supported the
entire family the extended family for
for decades and uh he he'd uh given half
his money to pop as he raged to his
daughter one day he said unlike Pop I
would expect you to give me half your
salary so um that's the context that
Hunter dropped off the laptop and never
returned to pick it up despite all the
incriminating evidence on it um
incriminating of his father uh as much
as him okay so so what are we what are
we supposed to make of that like I'm
trying to understand this so first of
all I'm I'm thinking about it the way I
would think about it if I heard this
story from a client so the first thing
I'd wonder
is um the timing is suspect like why
would you drop off those laptops a week
before your father announces his run for
president it seems it seems uh to call
it careless is to barely scrape the
surface especially when you know
perfectly well what's on those laptops
not only this U Treasure Trove of
homemade pornography which is like a
Highly Questionable Enterprise and and
of itself you have to wonder actly what
motivates someone to continually film
himself engaging in sexual activity with
with all the various hookers that he was
consorting with in strippers and so
forth there's a narcissism about that
that's quite remarkable um but also
there's a there's a vindictive
carelessness about it that's also Market
because it's not one laptop it's three
and three is a lot and they're rif with
information that's devastating
personally right I mean you wouldn't
think you'd be sharing your homemade
pornography with the world and and also
there's this immense amount of detail
about all of these
business enterprises that have been
accumulating for
decades what is an observer to make of
that no is is he is he that addled that
he didn't even noticed that this was
foolish or is there is there a desire to
be caught because that's certainly a
possibility or is there revenge against
his whole family including his father I
mean I I don't know how to make heads or
Tales of this because it's so utterly
preposterous it's it's not surprising in
some ways I suppose that one of the
reactions of the broader media was to
assume that this couldn't possibly be
real because when you read it and I mean
I'm still recovering from reading your
book and I want to delve into that as
deeply as possible to establish let's
say its credibility but I I really I'm
taken aback by the material that that
you reported in laptop from hell I I
don't know what to make of it I was
thinking about what I would do in Joe's
position in so far as I'm able to do
that so now I have a son and he's I'm
speaking as Joe here I have a son and
he's he's a bit of a juvenile delinquent
let's say except he's not a juvenile
he's 50 and so he's about 30 years past
the uh due date on juvenile delinquency
and he's rocking up a fair Fairly High
Financial bill on the hooker and cocaine
front and the penthouse in Las Vegas
he's acting like the evil son of a
Hollywood villain in every possible way
what am I supposed to do with him and
the first thing I would think if I had
any sense is well how about I don't put
him in a situation where he has more
money than God because that's the last
thing you want to do with someone
who's addict let's say especially to
Something Like Cocaine because an
unlimited supply of money means an
unlimited supply of drugs then you might
think well I'm also president and my son
is behaving in a way that well doesn't
exactly shed a positive light on the
family but also is dangerous in all
sorts of ways maybe I shouldn't be
taking them on my business trips there
is a plan maybe I shouldn't be
introducing him to world leaders all
over the all over the planet especially
in Russia and China and Ukraine for
example or in you know any number of
other corrupt countries that we might
mention maybe I should have
him for his own good supervised you know
and for the country's good so that he
straightens himself out and doesn't get
in a tremendous out amount of trouble
instead of enabling him at every turn
and and then what and then what tangling
us up in
Ukraine in a way that's morally
hazardous to say the least like I look
at the situation in Ukraine I read your
book I looked at Hunter Biden's dealings
with parisma I think well is there a 5%
overlap between the Biden's Financial
interests and the fact that we're in a
bloody war or a 1% overlap because the
right amount of overlap is absolutely
zero when we're talking about war with
Russia so you went through this you've
been living it for a long time
like what position did you start with
when you started assessing the laptop
material and what happened to you and
the way you were looking at things as
you walked through it yeah look I um I
sort of came to it disgusted I guess
because you know opening up the laptop
there's just so much sorted material
there um I ended feeling sorry for
Hunter and feeling utter um contempt for
Joe Biden and also feeling that Joe
Biden is a really bad person um as you
said what kind of a loving father puts
his addicted son in front of a torrent
of unaccountable cash and that's what he
did um you know it wasn't that he was
just enabling Hunter Hunter was a an
integral part of the family influence
pedling business Hunter was the bagman
um you know there's a video where you
can see taken quite some time go hunter
is quite young um he every job that
Hunter had um every you know University
position that he had was due to his
father he didn't have the marks to get
into Yale law school and so favors were
done um he his first job out of college
was at a wildly inflated salary for one
of Joe's donors in Delaware and from his
salary he complained that he had to pay
not just his um College fees off but
also his brothers
um that was the way Joe worked it you
know he he posed as the poorest man in
Congress uh while living a champagne
lifestyle while um not really having any
bills to pay the usual bills that normal
middle class families worry about like
you know helping their children get
through get to the you know the best
college they can and pay somehow paying
the bills uh getting them to private
schools getting the grandkids in the
into the same thing uh you know
internships judgeships uh
fellowships cushy government jobs you
name it all of these things were there
for the taking for Joe's extended family
and um and you
know I know that Joe Biden spent his
entire life building this mythology
around himself that he's a good family
man a devout
Catholic modest Joe workingclass Joe
lunch tell Joe um and it's all a lie um
he's the family part I think is
intriguing because um Joe Biden's always
had a um you know a Fascination um or a
desire to be like the Kennedy Clan and
so he's constructed a life and a family
uh sort of image that's very similar to
that um and there was a a fascinating
interview that he did with Kitty Kelly
when he was just uh newly in in the
Senate newly widowed um and he was very
cocky and uh would talk about um she
said he dressed like Great Gatsby you
know Gatsby esque very well dressed and
um he would talk about himself as uh you
know having had the the the greatest
wife that any man could have had and
their sex life was just brilliant and no
man's ever experienced that and uh not
not in a sort of a moring way but in a
boastful way um and just talking about
himself in a way that you know like he
said Rose Kennedy the Kennedy matriarch
keeps on inviting him over for Jenner
but he's too busy um and you know sort
of boasting that the kennedies are his
friends and and that they're throwing
themselves at him uh but you know he he
sort of fobs them off um so he's a very
peculiar person and I think he and he
also has always it's not just that he's
cognitively challenged now and he tells
lies and Tall stories he's always been a
fabulous he's always lived in this kind
of delusional Fantasy World um where he
sort of self- aggrandizes and creates
these stories about himself as the
Conquering Hero even if he never was in
the place like he was never with Nelson
Mandela or he was never at Ground Zero
or um all these places that he puts him
self in and um I don't even know if he
really understands what he's doing but
it's it's a pathology and um and so I
think to myself about someone like
Hunter you know this little motherless
boy who's a bit
ADHD um bit hyperactive very smart and
um he has this father who's Mercurial
and not there very often and has this
huge job that's obviously more important
and the entire family Revol around Joe
and it always has his mother put Joe on
a pedestal and all the siblings roles
were to uh serve Joe and and so Joe as
an adult that's the way his own family
behaves and then there's the stepmother
Jill Biden who comes in when Hunter's
around about uh eight or nine who
doesn't who who Hunter anyway feels
doesn't like him she loves Bo his older
brother by one year um but she doesn't
she Hunter feels that she just doesn't
like him and so that's a huge burden and
if a father that lies all the time I'm
sure broke promises all the time um is
very
destabilizing and um and you
know another example of Joe's cynical
exploitation of his family is that um he
had just been uh won an election to be
sen to be a senator right this was the
the biggest thing in his life and his
family's life he was only 29 years old
he was 30 by the time he was sworn in
the youngest Senator and um his wife
dies in a car crash tragically just a
few days before Christmas while he's
away in Washington and um and their baby
daughter is also killed and Hunter and
his brother Bo are like two and three
years old and they're very badly injured
and so this is a just a a devastating
block over this young uh Senator elect
and um so he he ends up being sworn in
at the hospital bed of his children and
so he invites all the the you know the
world's photographers into this hospital
room and he sets up a Podium there and
he's sworn in and all the photographs
show in the foreground these poor one
little motherless boys uh bandaged
Hunter has a brain injury his brother B
has a broken leg um and they're just
listlessly lying in bed while in the
background their father is being sworn
in and I just you know that that
photograph touched the heart of
everybody I mean you would have to be
completely heartless not to feel great
sympathy for this poor widower and his
poor little boys right but you also
might be wondering why that photo op is
staged that way if you were particularly
cynical and curious exactly and that's
that that's that's what I came to think
afterwards how cynical it was of him to
do that and he's used that photograph in
every campaign since and and so it takes
on a new very Sinister light I think
well okay so I want to go two directions
I want to return to the laptop I want to
talk about Mac Isaac and his attempts to
bring the laptop to the attention of the
FBI and then the eventual press response
but before we do that I want to talk
about delve a little bit more into
Hunter and his business Acumen so you
know I've had a lot more economic
opportunities put in front of me in the
last four or five years and that makes
interacting with my family it allows us
a lot more opportunities but it's also
complex because once you have a lot of
opportunities personally it's hard to
know exactly how many opportunities to
offer your family members let's say your
children because you want to offer them
opportunity but you want them to stand
up on their own two feet and to do
things for themselves and so when I was
reading your book I was thinking okay
well Joe is in a position to offer
Hunter opportunities and um people do
that for their children and as your
opportunities multiply it gets harder to
draw exactly the lines but you don't
want to put your kids in a position
where their opportunities exceed their
capabilities and so what I kept
wondering when I was reading the book
was well Hunter is being put in front of
all these International leaders let's
say business
people if you were going to make a case
for Hunter's business Acumen and
ability how would you do that because it
looked to me like the opportunities were
not proportionate to the ability I
couldn't tell what it was that Hunter
had to offer apart from access to his
father and if you were trying to defend
him you know in good faith he has a
legal degree he has a legal degree from
Yale he's he's intelligent by your own
admission it's like why isn't the story
that Hunter is running his business
Affairs as an independent individual why
isn't that an acceptable story if it's
not um look I mean I I think that that
the business really wasn't a business I
mean they didn't have a product they
weren't manufacturing anything um the
business was influence it was it was
contact with his father it was um uh you
know at at at one point his uncle um Jim
Jo Biden's younger brother um decided
that they were going to go into the
business of selling uh gas to from
Louisiana from Monkey Island uh to the
Chinese and so there was something it's
all it's all sort of business deals and
there were always other people um
Hunter's business partners who took care
of the sort of pesky details um like
setting up a business um and doing the
due diligence for it and so on that was
something Tony balinsky was brought in
to try and legitimize what they were
doing um but the the fact is that Hunter
was not interested in business he found
it incredibly boring what he had always
wanted to be was a an artist or a writer
and look I mean he's now both you know
he's written his Memoir um and and he's
also doing paintings and uh I know
that's a grift in itself and it the way
the White House has handled that has
been appalling and um the art world is
known for uh money laundering and and so
on so um it's it's not the wisest choice
but still I mean my sister's a a good
artist and she looked at Hunter's art
and she said it's good so there is
something there I mean you know and he's
um the reason I feel sorry for him is I
think that this is someone who has been
utterly crushed and um you know by his
father not really crushed but but sort
of manipulated ated by his father and I
guess it's to his credit that he really
hasn't been crushed I mean it's his
freedom is expressed itself in this sort
of malevolent way that he's just so
destructive to everybody around him and
in into his addictions uh and his utter
selfishness but um but you know this is
this is someone whose father just
treated him as a as a spare as a as um
as you know the bagman as just for
utility
uh because the oldest son Bo was The
Golden Child who also was being treated
as an object in in a way as sort of the
apple of his father's eye who was going
to uh continue the the sort of Dynasty
the dynastic Ambitions of Joe Biden and
become president after Joe so okay so
you pointed to something fairly specific
there you know because I said well you
know how do you if you're trying to
offer your children opportunities how do
you justify that and one of the things
you alluded to was while you look for
where their talents genuinely lie and
try to Ally the opportunities with those
talents and you pointed out that Hunter
can write and maybe he's got some
artistic ability I've looked at his
paintings and they could be a lot worse
than they are like I see some Talent
there the prices that are being
commanded for them are well the art
world is a very strange place so we
won't say too much about that but there
the prices are certainly a hell of a lot
higher than 99% of artists would ever
receive for doing anything no matter how
spectacular in the course of their
entire lifetime so but but you point out
that as far as you can tell on the
business front which is what we're
speaking about there is actually no
business there and so I have my children
involved in my business Affairs my
daughter is running this new Enterprise
that we hope to turn into an online
university and my son runs a software
company but they've done the bulk of the
work on both of those projects and they
actual projects they have an actual
There's an actual uh what there's an
actual product there we have actual
customers we right they're actual
businesses and I don't feel that
I've smoothed the road for them in an an
appropriate way because all of these
opportunities would have been sitting
there languishing if they W wouldn't
have taken the ball and seriously run
with it and so that's what you want to
do if you have opportunities at hand for
your kids is
you try to figure out a situation where
if they work hard and act appropriately
then they're going to benefit and
hopefully bring benefit to other people
at the same time and then there's no
cost in that to anyone and I'm when I
was reading your book I was trying to
give Hunter the benefit of the doubt
partly for the reasons that you describe
you know he's had the whole family's had
their fair share of tragedies and you
have to write that into the story but
for the life of me I couldn't figure out
what in the world he could could have
possibly be been selling except for
alliance with the family name and Joe
should have regarded that as an extreme
moral hazard and we should all regard
that at the moment as I said earlier as
a bloody extreme moral hazard given that
we're at war with Russia for all intents
and purposes and so this just isn't
acceptable you know and you said you
feel sorry for Hunter and I can
understand that too um and I think the
family is capitalized on that sympathy
but by the same token at some point you
cross the line from victim to
perpetrator and it seems to me you know
maybe this is just my judgmental self
but his his behavior on the sexual front
in particular like veers into
perpetrator rather than victim now you
go out of your way in your book to point
out there's absolutely no evidence as
far as you can tell that he veered into
say underage sexual activity and so
that's a very important thing to point
out but the what he's doing with his
hookers and his strippers and his
homemade porn is hardly wholesome family
friendly Affair and that in itself apart
from the business dealings might have
been enough so that an intelligent
father who was also simultaneously
president would have put some damn
serious walls between him and his son
and maybe also around his son and that
clearly failed to happen so at best we
have a situation where the father is
enabling and at worst we have a
situation where he's where what his he's
benefiting from the position that he put
his son in in the same way perhaps that
he benefited by by having those
photographs taken when he
was when he was confirmed for Senate I
mean it's a damn ugly story right those
are vicious those are vicious
accusations and so they're rough things
to Levy but as I said going through your
book why should people believe you like
why shouldn't they just think well
here's you know Miranda Divine mck ring
journalist and she's taking this laptop
and doing everything she possibly can to
you know to portray it in the worst
possible light to for her own self
grandis journalists certainly do that so
why do why should people listening and
watching regard you as a credible figure
do you
think well I guess I mean it's not me
it's it's the evidence um that's that's
what the the book is I mean it's just
laying out and trying to distill in
order this mess of a laptop um and you
know every every part of it is straight
from the laptop I haven't invented
anything um and I verified uh the
material that I used by talking to um
various of Hunter Biden's Associates and
former partners who um who whose names
are on the laptop who were CCD into um
into emails and were part of businesses
and you know their names appear on
documents um for instance I mean one I
can name is Tony balinsky who was
Hunter's uh business partner in the the
final sort of Chinese deal with
CFC and uh he Tony balinski I have the
contents of his three devices that he
also handed over to the FBI just before
the 2020 election and um that overlaps
with and corroborates um that Chinese
section of the of the laptop um and I
mean recently Devon Archer has uh come
come Out of the Shadows he's another of
Hunter Hunter's sort of former business
partners but also hunter called him his
best friend in business and in fact
Devon um he's quite a wholesome person
didn't didn't share any of Hunter's um
Hunter's
vices um he was doing the Lion Share of
uh you know setting up businesses and um
you know organizing things so that all
that Hunter had to do was fly into some
town and uh and you know get into a suit
and stop smoking crack for a couple of
hours and just go and meet these Chinese
or whoever um and so Devon Archer also
has testified
um before this Congressional um
committee and um verified a lot of the
material um that I've written about um
and I think just as time has gone on
it's now you know almost three years um
there's nothing in the book that hasn't
been um you know verified over and over
or corroborated or um proven no one has
proven anything wrong and the laptop
even though Hunt is still being koi
about you know it's oh maybe it's my
laptop or you know maybe it's not my
laptop maybe it's Russian disinformation
um whatever um he he he's he's you know
his lawyers are suing um people for
breach of privacy John Paul MAAC for
instance for breach of privacy for
exposing his material which he admits is
his material so it's a it's a confusing
sort of position to take have you ever
heard of data Brokers they're the
middlemen collecting and selling all
those digital Footprints you leave
online they can stitch together detailed
profiles which include your browsing
history online searches and location
data they then sell your profile to a
company that delivers you a targeted ad
no biggie right well you might be
surprised to learn that these same data
Brokers are also selling your
information to the Department of
Homeland Security and the IRS so to mask
my digital Footprints I protect myself
with expressvpn one of the easiest ways
for Brokers to aggregate data and tie it
back to you is through your device's
unique IP address which also reveals
information about your location when
you're connected to expressvpn your IP
address is hidden that makes it much
more difficult for data Brokers to
identify who you are expressvpn also
encrypts 100% of network traffic to keep
your data safe from hackers on public
Wi-Fi that's why I have the expressvpn
app download downloaded on all of my
devices phone computer and even my home
Wi-Fi router all I do is tap one button
to turn it on and I'm protected it's
that easy make sure your online activity
and data is protected with the best VPN
money can buy go to expressvpn.com
Jordan that's expressvpn.com Jordan for
three extra months free expressvpn.com
Jordan let okay so well and well and
you're still standing and you're not
like tied up in court for defamation Etc
and it has been quite a while since you
published the book let's go back to Mac
Isaac for a minute and continue the
laptop story okay now in your book you
said that and you and you just
elaborated on that now because you know
one of the things people might be
wondering is well what the hell is this
laptop shop owner go combing through
this hard drive for to begin with that's
really not his business but you
accounted for that you said that that
was partly a fluke on the technical side
that because he had to keep rebooting
the laptop and monitoring the upload he
was he was uh confronted with the
material and then that started to make
him nervous now you detailed this in
your book that Mach Isaac actually got
extremely nervous once he realized what
was on the laptop and he went to the FBI
is that correct is that have I got that
right and then the FBI did pick up the
laptop and so let's lay lay that let's
lay that out to the point where the
contents of the laptop start to be made
public by the New York Post because the
next absolutely hideous and despicable
sequence of events that occurs is that
the New York Post breaks the story
essentially and then the powers that be
shut it down in all sorts of ways right
Facebook does Twitter does um but even
more
stunningly you have dozens of security
Personnel working for the government
attributing the contents of the laptop
to Russian disinformation and this is
just prior to the election okay so let's
go back to Mac Isaac he's looking
through this laptop he's starting to
short out he just runs this little shop
and a bomb is being dropped into his lap
he goes to the FBI that's correct what
does the FBI do and then how does the
story break Giuliani gets involved how
does the story break well firstly what
happens is that in the background here
you have the impeachment um the sort of
Prelude to the impeachment of Donald
Trump uh Donald Trump's made a phone
call with the Ukrainian president
zalinski the new Ukrainian president and
um during that public phone call um he
says you know can you do me a favor and
and H investigate what's been going on
with Joe Biden and Hunter Biden and
brisma basically um and uh because this
had been talked about I mean it was very
unseemly at the time the New York Times
The Wall Street Journal uh that those
sort of mainstream organizations media
organizations that are now uh trying to
explain away um these problems were
actually reporting that it was pretty
UNT that Joe Biden's son was um you know
on the board of this corrupt Ukrainian
Energy company and what they didn't know
was that he was making a million dollars
a year so so this was sort of the buzz
in the background and the word barisma
came up and um John Paul ma ISAC is a
was a trump supporter no crime in that
um and he was alert to the the sort of
details of this looming impeachment and
he remembered the name barisma so he
went back and he scoured through the
laptop and he found all these documents
and that that was really what made him
scared because he's in Delaware the way
he explains it is the Biden's own
Delaware um he was afraid that something
would happen to him so he um he in fact
he made several copies um he uh put one
in an envelope and sent it to a friend
and said don't open this only open it if
something happens to me that was how
frightened he was and he contacted the
FBI but he did it through a Securus
route through his father an uncle or
something um in New Mexico and they got
rebuffed um and really quite rudely um
and he he made a couple of efforts and
and nothing nothing happened this is
from sort of like September and then
November of 2019 he finally gets a phone
call and he's asked about um this laptop
and in December December 9 uh two FBI
agents turn up at his doorstep question
him he tells them he's got a very um
forensic mind so he's really had figured
out the what he felt were the most
problematic um things on the laptop I
mean what he thought were crimes and so
he laid it all out for them and uh and
then he was frightened because he said
there one of the FBI agents left he said
because he was worried about his own
safety and he said what what will I do
and one of the FBI agents he claims said
to him well in our experience nothing
happens to people who don't talk you
know who don't open their mouth so he
took that when he told me that I thought
well you know I can understand you're
being paranoid if that sounds very
far-fetched but as the sort of cover up
and the FBI involvement in it has has
come to light uh I look back on that
conversation and think well maybe he
wasn't so off base uh so so what the
hell did he have to
gain well exactly I mean what he was
what he was what he said to the FBI what
he was hoping was he felt this was
exculpatory information for Donald Trump
to use in the upcoming impeachment and
he wanted the FBI to know that and he's
a very you know his father was in the
the um in the military his uncle was in
the military he's a very Law and Order
sort of guy and he really had faith that
the FBI would do the right thing and
that's why he was so desperate for them
to take it and he thought good well I've
I've gotten that off my conscience I'm
now protected and H no one will come and
try and kill me for this which is really
what he was worried about um but then
the months ticked by and nothing
happened and the impeachment was going
on and he just thought this is
ridiculous you know why does no one
knows so he tried to contact UM various
Republicans he tried Jim Jordan and
lindsy grah and you know sent faxes and
emails and phone calls and no one ever
got back to him and um then he saw R
juliani uh who was then president
Trump's lawyer on television and talking
about barisma in Ukraine and so he tried
him as a kind of a last ditch effort he
sent an email and um lo and behold Rudy
giuliani's lawyer a guy called Bob
Costello who served with him at the
southern district of New York a very
buttoned up very sharp lawyer um was
intercepting Rudy's mail at that time uh
for I don't know why security reasons or
something um and uh he saw this letter
and it was a very uh email it was a very
well written email very detailed very
precise um and he thought well this guy
might be something he called him
ascertained that he seemed on the up and
up and got him to FedEx a a copy of the
hard drive um to his home in Long Island
and uh and then when he opened it up he
um just saw evidence he was Bob Costello
was the um I think Deputy head of uh the
Criminal Division of the southern
district of New York so he knows crimes
when he sees them and he said he saw a
lot of crimes on this laptop so he calls
Rudy and uh they then this is sort of
August late August of of uh 2020 and so
they then spent spend the next 6 weeks
or so just doing their due diligence on
this trying to figure out if it's you
know legit if it's real if it's on and
they satisfied themselves up to a point
where they felt they could hand it to
the media without looking like fools um
they brought Steve Bannon in at the last
minute uh to help with some of the
Chinese names because Steve's got a lot
of uh connections there but Steve Bannon
did not get a copy of the hard drive
they did not give him one they were very
close with of that
information and then Steve Bannon
started uh sort of alluding to it in the
media um and uh he and and he started um
you know and Rudy did as well trying to
get various media to uh pay attention to
it okay so one one side Venture here and
then back to the story breaking in the
New York Post so Trump is being hauled
over the coals at this point for Russian
collusion
and when is it that Biden is in contact
with the Ukrainian authorities to get
the prosecutor who's going after brisma
fired so that was in uh December of
2015 um he first uh tied the1 billion do
in US Aid to um the firing of Victor
shoken and um he did that uh pretty much
off his own bat I mean it was us policy
uh State Department policy to um to
clean up corruption in the prosecutor
General's office um Victor shoken um had
been brought in uh just about a year
before actually less than a year before
he'd been brought in in February 2015 as
a kind of A Clean Skin by uh poroshenko
who was the American back president of
Ukraine um to clean things up because
there had been a huge scandal with his
predecessor um the uh do you want me to
go back into into the details of that
well yeah well there's there's there's a
loose end here I guess for me and and
that is well um Trump is being accused
of of collaborating inappropriately with
members of a foreign country Russia in
this case but we also have at the same
time Biden who's made reference to this
on the world stage getting a prosecutor
fired and my understanding is that that
prosecutor was going after barisma and
and have I got that right okay and it's
the same barisma that Hunter is involved
in and that's paying him a million
dollars a year yeah so barisma was owned
by uh a guy called slfi um who was an a
you know a mini they call him a
billionaire um and it was but but behind
slfi was a really ious oligarch called
eigor kisi um who would have people's
eyeballs uh gouged out um but he was um
and and zesi had been a minister in the
previous yanukovich government which had
been sort of Russia aligned um and the
uh the Americans wanted him out and I
mean I I don't I don't think it's
controversial or incorrect to say that
the the CIA was involved D in uh the
coup um you know how much they were
involved whether they nudged or whether
they were more involved uh who knows but
they certainly were involved and um and
so uh yanukovich was thrown out and he
sort of corrupt as that I mean Ukraine's
the most corrupt country in Europe one
of the most corrupt countries in the
world um and all the ministers fled uh
from that government taking billions of
dollars of Ukrainian people's money
except for one u a guy called mikolai
zfy who owned barisma while he did flee
to Russia initially and then to Dubai he
was allowed to keep his business his oil
and gas business barisma and to continue
to make money from it which I think is a
curious Point um Everybody every other
person involved with that yanukovich
government um was forced out and had to
flee but uh leeski while he wasn't
allowed back in the country could
continue to earn money and in fact could
put Americans like Hunter Biden and his
friend Devon Archer onto the board of
his company to try and uh legitimize it
and uh and keep the American sweet um
and to put pressure on Ukrainian
authorities not to investigate him um
and uh you know Victor shoken um was
brought in as I said after a scandal and
the Scandal was that his predecessor who
ran the prosecutor General's office a
guy called urea had presided over um the
collapse of a case that had been brought
by the British serious fraud Squad in
conjunction with the FBI against slfi
they had Frozen $24 million of slf's
money in a London uh bank account and uh
this was a very important case for the
serious fraud sort because it was um the
showpiece uh that the the you know the
government was boasting about and head
of uh the serious fraud Squad had a
whole conference about um that they were
going to claw back the illg gotten gains
of uh the Ukrainian uh oligarchs that
had been banished from that country
because they were aligned with Russia so
this was a really important case and a
bribe was paid uh to uh the prosecutor
General's office people in the
prosecutor General's office and um and
the case collapsed and um
the money a British
judge unfree Froze that money and zfy
could take it back and so this was
hugely embarrassing to the US Embassy
which really was running things in
Ukraine and um they were being pressured
the the Ambassador Jeffrey Patt was
getting a lot of grief from the British
who were completely Furious about the
fact that you know they blamed the
Americans for this happening why didn't
you have control over this corrupt
prosecutor 's office and poreno the
president was under pressure as well so
he brought in this guy reluctantly
Victor shoken who was um sort of a you
know kind of a superstar he was a very
popular prosecutor he was always a line
prosecutor had never wanted to be a boss
um and he had been responsible for some
very high-profile convictions and uh you
know he was quite flamboyant in the way
for instance one time he busted a corrup
politician and he went into the rer the
par the Ukrainian Parliament and he
played video um and to to all the
parliamentarians of uh this this guy
sort of clandestine video of this
politician accepting a bribe or asking
for a bribe getting one um and and you
know that was a major story and he'd
also um uh arrested um The Killers of
this uh of this journalist who'd been
beheaded and his body trussed up and
left in a forest and that was as uh um
you know he he'd been um writing stories
that were damaging to the previous
regime and various oligarch so he he
also uh busted that um story and that
that case open and arrested those people
and he was still pursuing the people
behind them the powerful people behind
them so he was kind of a without fear or
favor prosecutor he'd already suffered a
one assassination attempt when a sniper
um uh fired through a window in a
meeting he was at um and
so he was a sort of a good choice for
poroshenko to appoint as the prosecutor
General and shoken says that he didn't
want to do it um but he agree he knows
it's political and you you know politics
in Ukraine is very ugly um and so but
anyway he reluctantly took it because he
said penko appealed to his patriotism
and uh you know I've spent a lot of time
talking to shoken and um I mean not in
his I can't speak Ukrainian and he can't
speak English but through translators
and and through Google translate and um
he does strike me as a a very patriotic
um proud Ukrainian and proud of his
record as a prosecutor and there's
evidence that he's given me to show that
he was a very successful prosecutor and
as prosecutor General there every year I
mean there's a lot of bureaucracy there
and a lot imposed uh by the Americans
and Europeans on the prosecutor
General's office so there was a lot of
reporting going on and he's shown me
reports where his uh Pro you know he had
three times as many prosecutions of
corrupt people um as either of his two
predecessors so you know there is some
evidence and I've also seen kind of in
the background where he lives and he
doesn't seem to live lavishly um and so
um you know I I can't see any evidence
that he's corrupt and no one has ever
brought forward any evidence that he's
corrupt so how did Biden how did Biden
have him fired and why well um well
shoken says that he was investigating
lfy and barisma at the time and there is
evidence for that because in February of
2016 about six weeks before he was
removed shoken um issued a warrant for
seizing all of zf's property in Kiev and
that was you know a couple of mansions
three plots of land a Rolls-Royce Silver
Phantom car um that's uh you know that
was reported in the Ukrainian media and
but in other European media as well and
so that's established that that happened
and no one's ever denied that um and so
you know that's evidence that what
shoken is saying is true is that he was
he he said he had more than one case he
had several cases a foot of um against
lfi for money laundering and Corruption
and um and so on and uh and so you know
therefore I come at this from well why
are these lies being told by Joe Biden
by his allies also by people um at the
Atlantic Council um people who are sort
of affiliated with that that sort of
with sort of the Atlantic council is
sort of the NATO front so with NATO
people um and and the sort of Russia
Hawks um that abound in American
Academia they all backed um Joe Biden
also there were some Europeans as well
but again I've um you know interviewed
for instance a guy called Jan tuminski
who's uh was the EU ambassador to
Ukraine at that time he was quoted as um
welcoming you know shoken removal and uh
there was always um anonymous uh sources
quoted by The Washington Post New York
Times and um the and so on Bloomberg um
uh and Financial Times um all saying
that the Europeans the EU wanted shoken
gone because he was corrupt but Jan
toiny when I interview him said no um
look I I knew there were problems in the
prosecutor General's office and it all
comes back to that bribe that was paid
in the the zesi um serious fraud Squad
um case in London falling apart
everybody was up in arms about that but
that was not shoken um and chinsky says
I didn't make any comment about shoken
because that wasn't those kind of
details were up to the ukrainians which
is the proper way to behave and not only
that I mean you know I found a European
commission report from 20 December of
2016 um in fact it was um about a week
after Joe Biden uh traveled to Ukraine
on December 9th and gave that ultimatum
to poreno that you fire shoken or you
don't get the billion dollars in Aid um
this European commission report was the
final report um of their sort of
investigation and sort of riding Ukraine
to do various things including and very
importantly to clean up corruption um in
order to qualify for Visa free travel
which was very important to Ukraine and
um this report said yes they've
satisfied everything and in fact um they
can they now can qualify for Visa free
travel and on the corruption front
they've done very well there's been a
lot of progress and they actually
identified Shen's office as having made
strides including setting up a new
anti-corruption um office inside the
prosecutor General's office and that um
shoken had just appointed someone to
that um and and you know there are
letters as well from um from the summer
you know August September um of 2015
from John kery and Victoria nulan John
KY who was then the Secretary of State
Victoria nulan was a senior State
Department person um congratulating
shoken to Victor shoken I've seen them
saying you know good on you for your
progress and your good work that you're
doing the Bible is the root of all
wisdom inspiration and spiritual
nourishment the Hallow app empowers you
to explore the Bible's profound
teachings and to effortlessly
incorporate them into your daily life a
great place to start while you deepen
your understanding of the Bible is to
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the Hallow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections
here you can dive into an extensive
library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and Audi guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey hallow provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before studying the
Bible's literary Brilliance has
influenced countless writers poets and
artists throughout history by studying
the Bible yourself you'll gain a deeper
appreciation for the power of
Storytelling symbolism and metaphor
enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres the
Hallow app also helps you connect with a
community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hall.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today down
download the Hallow app at hall.com
Jordan that's hall.com
Jordan hall.com Jordan for an exclusive
3-month free trial of all 10,000 plus
prayers and
meditations that's that's
comprehensively dealt with I would say
let's go back to the emergence of the
laptop story in the New York Post so why
did the post decide to move ahead with
the story what did they initially report
and what was the
consequences well
so unbeknown to me I didn't really know
anything until I get a phone call from
sorry text message from it was late on a
Friday night from Bob Costello and um I
had been doing stories with Rudy Julian
I just arrived um in July of um 2019 in
America to do an 18mon stint cover the
election um because my former editor
colle Allen in Australia um was editor
of the or editorinchief of had been
editor-in chief of the New York Post he
um asked me to come um and do this this
18mth stint which I thought would be a
lot of fun and um the first thing I did
was befriend Rudy juliani because uh
when I lived in New York with my family
in earlier times when it was uh crime
ridden um uh you know I I had a lot of
um admiration for what Rudy Giuliani had
done as mayor of New York cleaning it up
and I knew that he was close to Donald
Trump so I figured if I wanted to cover
Donald Trump um I would Eng gratiate
myself with Rudy Giuliani which I did
and um I had just written a story um
about Rudy who'd been the first person
to talk to Donald Trump after he'd
gotten out of hospital um recovered from
coid and Rudy loved that story so I
guess I was top of Mind he'd been trying
to shop this story around to other media
and he had no nobody Buy fighting and
time was running out um you know and he
felt that he wanted to to get this out
in the media before Trump had to to a
debate against um the first debate
against Biden anyway so Bob Costello
sends me this text and he says look um
there are four photographs in it from
the laptop and he says this is a really
good story let's talk and so next day we
had a long conversation about you know
the the email from
uh jumpo Mac Isaac the crimes that were
on the laptop um and he talked to me
through it and uh he convinced me that
and he's he's a very serious person and
he convinced me that he'd done due
diligence on it enough to satisfy him
that he wasn't selling me a bill of
goods but obviously we would have to do
our own due diligence but it was enough
to make me think this is pretty big and
so I uh texted my editor um on the
Saturday night um call Allen and sent
him the photos and um then we had a
conversation and um and then he just
decided Well let's just put the entire
um you know Newsroom on this and it was
all guns blazing um reporter went down
to Delaware interviewed John Paul Mac
ISAC picked up the subpoena that the FBI
had given him to when they collected the
laptop picked up the work order with
Hunter Biden's sign picture on it um you
know we contacted people um who appeared
on the laptop um I didn't I wasn't doing
this reporting this was my colleague
Emma Joe Morris and other people in the
paper were doing this um and um look I
there was there was trepidation in The
Newsroom let's put it that way about
this story because because Steve Bannon
who had a bad reputation um for being
you know loose with the truth was
involved although he was much less
involved than you know other our our
competitors in the media claimed he
certainly wasn't involved with anything
I was doing um and Rudy giuliani's
reputation already had suffered somewhat
um and he' already been smeared as being
sort of a an agent of Russian influence
or you know victim of Russian influence
um and so uh you know and Ukraine was
sort of a dirty word I mean everyone was
nervous about it but to his very great
credit my and I don't think any other
Jour any other editor in America would
have done this but Cole Allen did it and
he said no I'm satisfied this is a great
story and remember this is three weeks
before the election yes and he pulled
the rip cord and our first story was uh
you know Biden secret emails on the
front page and it um mainly was about a
an email from uh a barisma Executives to
Hunter saying you know thanks very much
for introducing me to your father and uh
you know the The Peculiar behavior of
the Biden campaign too um made it raised
our suspicions because it was like to us
they were saying oh you know maybe there
was a meeting it's not on his official
schedule you know he meets a lot of
people to The Washington Post Etc no no
meeting ever occurred um and uh there
were all sorts of other strange things
but strangest of all we sort of expected
obviously in the middle of a very um
tough election campaign uh to get push
back from that side and from other media
but not from social media immediately we
we held the story until 5:00 a.m.
normally it would go out at 10:00 the
previous night but online we held it
till 5:00 a.m. and um and within um
three or four hours uh it had been shut
down and censored by uh Facebook and
Twitter and the first we knew of it was
uh a Facebook executive who also happens
to be very plugged into the Democrats um
just tweeted that uh Facebook was now um
going to I can't remember his exact
words but it was basically throttle the
reach of um of our story pending
factchecking right which they still
haven't they still haven't done the
factchecking as far as I can tell
because the first thing you would do
which is what we did if you're
factchecking is you would go to the
other people who appeared on the emails
that we were publishing and say hey did
you get this email and Tony balinsky was
already out there he wasn't hard to find
he was on the emails uh you could have
asked him but they have never contacted
him so some fact check and then Twitter
followed suit and who Twitter who at
Twitter do we know yes so now we know I
didn't know when I wrote the book but
the story of the cover up I think is
bigger than the story of corruption
which is you know Age Old Washington
story uh at Twitter were embedded um
various FBI and CIA X operatives
including uh in a very important role
was a guy called James Baker who was had
been the chief lawyer at the FBI did I
say that and he'd been parachuted eight
months before the election into Twitter
as their Deputy uh chief lawyer deputy
counil and um he was involved as we now
know from the Twitter files um in
discussions that morning October 14 2020
of whether or not to basically shut down
our story um and and the the excuse that
Twitter used was that we had violated
their hacked materials policy and that's
important it seems bizarre to us because
nothing about the story was hacked but
now we understand that for uh weeks
beforehand the FBI had been briefing uh
Twitter and Facebook although we don't
know as much about what they were
telling Facebook but I assume it was the
same thing um they'd been briefing
Twitter uh to look out uh in October
likely in October to look out for a
hacken leak operation hack and dumper
operation um of Russian disinformation
uh likely about Hunter Biden so and you
think that was a consequence of them
knowing what was on the laptop contents
because it had already been turned over
to them by
mcisaac partly that was they had had the
laptop since December 2019 but also
there's a hidden part of the story which
fits in which is that um the FBI had
been spying on Rudy Giuliani since
November of
2019 and which was about the time that
John Paul MacIsaac was um contacting the
FBI and saying he had this laptop right
so and Rudy Giuliani was the president's
um private lawyer so there was this
covert surveillance warrant on his cloud
and that meant that in August of 2020
when John Paul Mac ISAC sent that
voluminous detailed email to Rudy
Giuliani um the FBI if they were doing
their job would have had access to it so
they would have known the cats out of
the bag right and then they also would
have had access to his IM messages with
me now there wasn't a lot we mostly
spoke on the phone but there were a
couple of uh messages uh enough when I
looked back to see that um it was
obvious that the New York Post was
interested was going to publish I mean
one of them I said don't give it to
anyone else right we're you know it's
all systems go here so they knew it was
coming the medical establishment has
been disregarding the lives of innocent
babies for decades now many have grown
cold and callous because of the surreal
thought The Surreal reality that over 64
million babies have been lost pre-born
will not stand silent nor should we we
cannot stand by and let babies die at
the hands of abortion that's why
pre-born exists to stand up for those
who cannot defend themselves the only
defense for these precious babies is
their heartbeat which begins at just 3
weeks and can be heard on ultrasound by
5 weeks when a mother making that
ultimate Choice hears her baby's
heartbeat and sees the precious life
inside of her the majority of the time
she will choose Life by sponsoring an
ultrasound for a mother you are being
the voice of the pre-born please join
pre-born in the cause for life for just
$28 you can be the difference between
the life and death of a child dial pound
250 and say the keyword baby or visit
preborn
docomo all gifts are tax deductible and
you will never regret saving a child's
life that's pound 250 baby or visit
preborn
docomo well you know you just skipped
over something you know about 5 minutes
ago saying you know oh well by the way
this is probably as big a scandal as the
hunter laptop Hunter Biden laptop itself
and it's like well yeah I would say so
is the FBI is conspiring with Facebook
and Twitter to suppress the story about
the president's son being in cahoots
with uh Ukraine a Ukrainian energy uh
company three weeks before the election
yeah I would say that's like that's that
that makes Watergate look like nothing
like seriously part of the reason I
think that this story hasn't got
traction is that there's there's so much
explosive material in it that you can't
even keep track of it it's just one
Preposterous scandal after another and
now the New York Post got kicked off
Twitter entirely right wasn't not the
case I think I got kicked off Twitter
around the same time but you guys were
gone from Twitter right and now the New
York Post is the oldest newspaper in the
United States if I got that right very
influential newspaper but Twitter shut
you down completely so let me add throw
something else in here so of course I've
been watching your country from the
outside since I'm a Canadian and I've
been watching Trump play The Stolen
election uh uh song for well since the
election you know and I've thought a
couple of things about that I thought it
was offbrand for him to claim
victimization because Trump is the guy
who tromps around and says I always win
and in this case he didn't win and then
I've talked to many people who've been
analyzing the court cases where
corruption in the election has been
alleged and Trump has come out on the
losing side of the vast majority of
those and then I think well he's got the
details wrong with regards to the
election but he's got the meta narrative
right and because I can't help and this
isn't I'm not speaking as a trump
admirer here by the way um um be that as
it may one way or another his notion
that see my sense is if the bloody
laptop story hadn't been suppressed the
election wouldn't have gone the way it
went because it was a pretty narrow
margin and this is a pretty vicious
story and so the fact that the FBI
conspired with Facebook and Twitter to
collapse this story to to limit its
reach and then to attribute it to
Russian disinformation and then to have
the security Community come out now you
detail this in your book too there's
dozens of people from the security and
intelligence community that come out and
say oh this is definitely Russian
disinformation and one of the things you
point out in your book is they had
absolutely no evidence whatsoever to be
making that claim and so now all of a
sudden your story disappears and the New
York Post is off Twitter and it's 3
weeks before the election and it's a
very narrow election and it turns out
that Biden wins it's like well to call
that a scandal is to say almost nothing
it's and it's no wonder that Trump's
story that the election was stolen
resonates with his base even if it's not
stolen in the detailed way that he
describes there's certainly something
unbelievably rotten going up going on at
the highest possible levels of
essentially fascist collusion right
government the presidency the White
House itself the FBI the CIA Facebook
and Twitter all colluding to take down
the New York Post for reporting on the
corruption of Hunter Biden yeah you'd
kind of think that would be front page
story on on a place like the New York
Times for example if it wasn't corrupt
Beyond
Comprehension yeah not just corrupt but
I also wonder um you know since I've
been investigating this story I see um
you know the intelligence Community as
so embedded uh in social media you know
in Facebook and Twitter um and and and
manipulating behind the scenes and
censoring it's not just the Twitter
files it's this incredible court case
called Missouri versus Biden um where uh
the charge is that and a judge has
actually did find that the Biden
Administration is appealing that but
found that um the Biden administra the
government was um putting enormous
pressure on these social media companies
to censor
anything their narrative I mean whether
it was on coid on vaccines on the
Ukraine War uh memes about um Jill Biden
uh you know anything that that was
detrimental to the government was Vero
and the the government was holding over
these social media companies the threat
that the Republicans are into as well
that that ought to be followed through
on actually that they would break them
up and and use section 230 which which
allows them to escape the uh the normal
legal um constraints that a normal
publisher like the New York Post has um
but so that was the threat hanging over
them and you okay so so let's let's
delve into that for a second okay so now
we have a situation where the
president's office itself has been found
in violation of the First Amendment
direct violation of the First Amendment
it's not some accidental violation it's
a programmatic repeated violation of the
First Amendment and the journalists
let's say at the New York Times or at
CNN for that matter MSNBC aren't smart
enough to understand that a direct
assault on the First Amendment actually
well let's say threatens their
livelihood in so far as they're actually
acting as journalists so how do you make
sense out of the FBI CIA collusion with
the White House why the hell would they
do that and then what's going on with
the journalists like this is something
that just makes my jaw drop it's like of
all the things that you would think
would light a fire underneath
journalists it would be the assault by
politicians on the First Amendment so
like what the hell why why is this
happening well there two things there so
on the journalism I my feeling is that
if the social media companies are
basically controlled by intelligence
operatives so too must be the nework yor
times and the Washington Post The
so-call Prestige Brands they wouldn't
bother with the New York Post but the
New York Times for instance is an
incredibly powerful entity it dictates
it sets the agenda for newsrooms across
the world I've worked in um you know in
Australia as a journalist and and in
Britain and the the New York Times is
incredibly influential and it's sort of
all the news that fit that's fit to
print if it's in the New York Times you
can take it to the bank that has been um
the the you know its its brand and and
I've just seen through the Russia
collusion um stories and the stories
that I have done deep Dives on
particularly the laptop story that they
pedal lies outright lies and um and the
Washington post as well they do
factchecking you know when you actually
go back and look the shoken thing I know
I spent a long time talking about it but
there is layer upon layer of so many
lies and it's not just lies it's its
documents disappeared uh internationally
um it's it's a it's an operation it's
not just journalist being sloppy or one
corrupt journalist this is a concerted
operation the likes of which you would
get from you know spies so I don't know
exactly how it works but a rule of thumb
that someone told me is the state
department these days is about 50% CIA
so um you know and you you know in
there's various ways you can tell who's
CIA and who isn't in and they they these
spies operators diplomats so why are
they why are they so aligned why are
they so aligned with the Biden
Administration like I wouldn't think
that necessarily that the natural allies
of the security intelligence Community
would necessarily be the left-wing
Democrats like so so H how do you how do
you account for that it's not really
about that it's about well I mean partly
it may be but but because Washington you
know they're they're all from the swamp
and in Washington 90% of people vote
Democrat but I think it's something more
and I think this is why um Trump was
perceived as an existential threat
because actually when you look at his
presidency um he he just you know he
didn't do any he didn't start any wars
he didn't do anything dangerous uh he
you know the economy was ticking along
there was nothing outrageous he did he
really for all his rhetoric he was a
pretty conventional uh conservative
apart from he didn't buy the
neocon uh worldview this sort of
imperialist American um worldview where
you know it's not only you know in 911
it was um and I mean I I regret myself I
fell for all of that and I was all rah
for Iraq which I bitterly regret and and
now I'm very cynical about the lies that
I was told and bought then and I hear
now um from the same people and uh so I
think that that that that Trump just
didn't buy into that whole project it's
America first it's more the isolationist
streak um and you know he would ask uh
NATO why why aren't you pulling your
weight why aren't the Europeans paying
for their own military why are we having
to be the policemen of the world um why
can't we have a decent relationship with
Russia I mean it's just upending uh you
know Decades of sort of Cold War
mentality which has never gone away I
mean like he upended the like he upended
the Palestine narrative with regards to
the Abraham Accords exactly you know and
all for the good really well that was
something yes fresh thinking there and
and so I I think that is why he's an
existential threat because those people
who were the the deepest of the neocon
deep State really loathed him and you
see that in I mean the CIA letter uh by
the 51 former intelligence officials is
very um very instructive the the uh that
was a letter that was written just a few
days after our story came out and was
suppressed and it was designed we know
uh to help Joe Biden in the second
debate against Donald Trump in which
obviously uh the laptop from hell is
going to come up and um we now know
thanks to the uh oversight committee now
the Republicans are in control um that
that letter was organized by Mike Morell
who had been a former acting CIA
director and was on a promise to be
Biden's CIA director so he had a
personal motive So when you say it was
organized in what way what does that
mean exactly that letter so what we also
find is that Anthony blinkin now the
Secretary of State and a member of Joe
Biden's Inner Circle was working for the
Biden campaign he phoned Mike Morell uh
a day or two or maybe the same day Mel's
vague on it um that our story came out
and um and Mel said oh he didn't tell me
to write the letter but he would not
have written the letter if he hadn't had
the phone call from uh Anthony blinkin
and if Anthony blinkin hadn't sent him a
USA Today story which I have no doubt
was seeded by the intelligence Community
which said that the laptop was Russian
disinformation and so Mike Morel then
said about calling uh getting 51 former
most of them CIA people some like James
Clapper who's lied before congress not
not exactly an honest broker um he was
also R pulled in but there were five
former CIA directors or acting CIA
directors who signed that letter this
was a heavy duty letter and what they
said was well the message that it sent
was that the laptop and our story
therefore were Russian disinformation
way they wrote the letter and they try
to get out of now was very weasy they
they used a language like has all the
ear marks which is a we right of of a
Russian information
operation they used the weight of their
previous uh High careers in the CIA um
to to basically sign seal and deliver
this letter and Mike Morell says in his
emails to other people when he's trying
to recruit them to sign the letter that
um he wants to get in fact he tells John
Brennan former CIA director under Obama
who had a lot to do with the
destabilization of Ukraine he tells John
Brennan um uh you know I want to give uh
Joe Biden a talking point at the debate
you know a way to to how nice yeah well
the thing that struck me is so
Preposterous about that so you know when
that broke I thought well that's a lot
of former intelligence officials and you
know it's it's hard to imagine that
they're all colluded
but on the other
hand why in the world would the Russians
be so thrilled with Trump I mean you had
to buy that story right you had to
believe that Trump was somehow a natural
Ally of Russia and Putin and I mean I
know that Trump got along with Putin the
same way he got along with the
Preposterous leader of North Korea but
it certainly didn't seem to me that
there was any evidence to suggest that
Trump was the natural Ally of Russia and
so you had to buy that to believe that
the Russians would be so interested in
TR that they would go to all this work
to produce this you know complex form of
unbelievably sophisticated
disinformation in the form of a fake
laptop from Hunter dropped off in some
no account place in Delaware I mean none
of that makes any sense unless you know
you attribute like super spy
capabilities to some genius on the
Russian front which strikes me as you
know somewhat Preposterous and yet well
all 51 of these people signed this
document and so everyone find it without
without looking at the laptop without
asking to have a look at the hard drive
without details any due diligence I mean
they they had no evidence to say this
none and they just they they in fact
admitted in the letter they say you know
from our vast experience we've
ascertained you know this is exactly
this has the whole ear marks of a
Russian information operation so they
they abused their Authority they abused
the trust that the American people would
have in that Authority and uh and you
know it's it's extraordinary to me that
um they haven't apologized theyve you
know we have tried numerous times I've
tried I've you know
the I've sent emails I've phoned I've
I've called their bosses I've called the
think tanks they've um the bosses of the
think tanks that they're aligned to um
you know every which way we've had other
reporters do the same thing and um
there's just nothing from them it's just
just dead the one guy called David PRI
who was a CIA something or other um he
went on Fox News and he said he's happy
that he did it you know it's it was the
right thing to do by what by what
standard but because Trump is so evil
that every every possible um weapon used
against him is justifiable no matter
what is that the rationale well that's
the subject but no he had some he had
some bogus excuse can't even remember it
was so flimsy um but uh they you know
and I have spoken to someone who um
should have signed it had the
credentials to sign it um and didn't
sign it uh because he felt that it just
there was no basis for it he didn't want
to be involved in some political he just
saw it as a political hit and so that
would have been these people are very
Savvy I mean you'd expect them to be
they're high level CIA analysts and
directors you would expect that they
would sniff a rat and know that this was
political um of course they knew but as
you said they felt there was this sort
of this this illness that had um was
afflicting the intelligence Community um
and and all the forers which was that
Trump is an existential threat sure
that's right you see that you see that
in the reaction of people like Harris is
that Trump is such a threat that no
matter see it's so interesting to me to
see this happening because it's
happening on multiple fronts like we're
told by people continually that we Face
existential threats that are such that
all the normal rules should be upended
by moral people and those normal rules
could mean every single one of your
constitutional rights which is of course
what happened in the coid lockdown which
is now a disease that the doctors
according to MSNBC are having a
difficult time distinguishing from the
common cold you know so that's kind of a
problem and so we have emergency
emergency emergency climate climate
change well that's the that's the next
one that's the next one it's like
climate change is such an emergency that
every right thinking person is is
terrified into apocalyptic panic and so
you don't get to fly and you don't get
to have a car and you don't get to leave
your city and you don't get to eat meat
and and well you know quote we get all
the power and of course that has nothing
to do with any of this and so you know
one of the things that I've come to
conclude is that if you're listening to
someone who says the crisis is such that
your fear justifies my suspension of
your civil Liberties then you're talking
not to your ally in crisis and an
appropriate leader but to a tyrant in
sheep's clothing and this is exactly
what's happening with the on the Trump
front too it's like oh my God he's so
dangerous just like climate change and
coid that anything goes no matter what
because no matter what we do on our side
and we're the good guys it can't be
nearly as bad as Trump might do at some
unspecified point in the future it's
like well just about enough of this I
mean the story that you unfold and you
know we touched on the collusion part of
it here at the end it's right again FBI
CIA Facebook Twitter conspiring with the
Washington Post and the New York Times
to subvert what I would say is the is
the story of the biggest political
scandal in my lifetime like I was around
I was young during the Watergate
hearings and and the Nixon collapse and
that was nothing compared to this as far
as I can tell first of all it was you
know Nixon had his his hands in a
variety of relatively unseemly places
but not in as mult
spectacularly multi-dimensional manner
as this especially not when you factor
in the post Hawk Hunter Biden collusion
to silence the people who brought it to
public attention it's absolutely Beyond
Comprehension so how's your book done by
the way how many copies has it sold um
it's done very well it's sold in hard
cover um 200 like I can't
remember hundreds of thousands still
yeah yeah oh great no it's done very
well and then you know there's audio
book and um uh ebook has done very well
as right so so are there newspapers
other than the New York Post that have
carried the banner forward in the in the
Biden laptop
investigation or or no I mean there have
been obviously Fox News and conservative
um you know online Publications but no
um you know I I kept on hoping because I
know that there are at least I don't
know Washington Post but I know at the
New York Times that there are honest
journalists um and and some of them have
covered aspects of this and so you get
glimmers of Truth coming out but um you
know for instance it
took uh it was about oh March or April
um well after Joe Biden was in sconed in
the Oval Office in 2021 that the New
York Times finally came out and admitted
that yeah you know the laptop was real
authenticated some of these emails um
that was that by the way oh by the way
it was the 23rd paragraph of a story
that was buried somewhere and and and
then and then and then after that of
course because the New York Times sets
the agenda Washington Post everyone else
just tripped over themselves to do
similar and they all had this
boilerplate paragraph and it was uh
there is no evidence that Joe Biden you
know was involved or knew anything about
what was going
okay okay so so let's go let's go down
that because we're running out of time
here and there's so much more to cover
we haven't even covered the details of
the business involvement but but let's
do that okay so so I'll play Devil's
Advocate so so Hunter has been along for
the ride with his father but his father
is concerned about him and is keeping an
eye on him and why not you know offer
him a spot on the jet since it's sitting
there anyways we get to catch up and you
know do family things together and
Hunter I like to have Hunter along in my
meetings as he gives brings another set
of eyes to the situation and if he
happens to be doing some business on the
side well you know what's the problem
with that okay and and I'm arms length
from that completely I don't have a clue
what's going on and I'm certainly not
benefiting from this in any Financial
Manner and so like what's the big fuss
here everyone I'm just being a good
father and you know opening some doors
for my son okay so what's wrong with
that story what does how is Joe involved
and what's the evidence for that as far
as you're concerned well first all I
mean this is Joe Biden's business this
is how he has uh supported his family in
a Lavish Way uh lived in deont mansions
um and you know put all his kids through
schools and all his nephews and nieces
and so on um he's run an influence
pedaling operation that his family first
of all his brothers um ran for him out
of Delaware Delaware is a very peculiar
State it's like the Lenin of America it
has the most opaque corporate um laws
you know rules um and uh and practically
every corporation in America is
headquartered in Delaware that giv tiny
state that gives the senator from
Delaware this enormous power because he
has all these very wealthy companies
wanting favors from him also because
when he came into the Senate um he was
uh clay to be molded by the older
Senators there and they felt sorry for
him because he was newly widowed and so
they took him under his wing he doesn't
like to admit this but it was the sort
of um racist uh sort of Dixie crat
Senators who did that Democrats um and
he got these very high futin jobs
powerful jobs he was um for many years
chair of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee chair of the Senate um uh
Judiciary Committee uh therefore
Judiciary Committee had power over who
became judges um and also in the the
Foreign Relations Committee he was wooed
very early on by China he went over
there as a young Senator um was taken to
the equivalent of Martha's Vineyard for
a weekend and they filled his head with
uh you know propaganda he came back and
he was so embarrassingly pro-china that
the Weekly Standard had a front page uh
just excoriating him and saying he's an
embarrassment um and uh and and Joe
Biden as this very influential head of
the Foreign Relations Committee um in
2001 was instrumental in getting China
into the WTO which was a disaster for
American manufacturing for the very
American working class that Joe Biden
purports to care about um uh you know he
was very influential with his reluctant
Democrat colleagues I think the
Republicans were into it but the
Democrats weren't Bill Clinton wasn't
into it uh so so that was you know Joe
Biden for all his non and his clownish
behavior and his lies and his the fact
that he's he's laughed at uh by people
as sort of harmless toly Joe um he did
carry a lot of clout and he did make
things uh get legislation through for
those donors those credit card donors in
Delaware that were again to the
detriment of uh the little people and um
in return he uh you know got cheap
houses and his his previous uh less good
houses were bought at an inflated price
uh as I said his son got jobs at
inflated salary and who knows what else
uh it it it it worked for him so he had
this this influence pedaling operation
going on it was in his DNA in Delaware
and then when he became vice president
and Hunter now comes into the family
business he was already a lobbyist in in
Washington so that was working um and
now Joe starts flying him around the
world with him flew him famously to
China in 2013 to when when Joe was going
to China to do America's uh important
business like stop China from aggressing
in the South China Sea militarizing
those islands stop China stealing
America's intellectual property uh and
so on and Joe walked away from that
meeting with uh you know the Chinese CCP
leaders uh with nothing on behalf of
America but hunter walked away with uh a
10% in a Chinese firm that um had2 and a
half billion dollar okay okay so let's
focus on that for a minute so you just
laid out you know three concerns of
international importance particularly in
relationship to the US with regard to
China you said Biden came home from that
trip empty-handed but his son came home
with a substantial business Victory okay
so now it seems to me now tell me if I'm
wrong well I would say first of all well
that shouldn't H have happened
regardless of its
legal regardless of its legality it's a
clear moral
hazard right is that while Biden is
negotiating with the Chinese on these
important Affairs his son shouldn't be
negotiating business deals on the same
trip especially business deals that
benefit the bidens okay so now how if
you're a Democrat how do you argue
against that proposition like am I
missing something here how is that not
inappropriate well this is how Joe Biden
does it he uses the grief card again um
it's always about um you know because
his oldest son the apple of his eye
tragically died of brain cancer yeah
that that um that is overlaid you know
we we're told always that that Joe was
so devastated that his AIDS didn't dare
bring up the case about barisma for
instance because that was around that
time um you know anytime uh Joe is in
hot water you just see this throughout
his career what they they bring up uh
the tragedy of his wife and daughter
dying the tragedy of his son dying later
on and you know Joe when he's in trouble
I mean I hate to say this because it
sounds so awful and maybe I am being too
cynical but he will manage to get
himself photographed um at church
walking through the graveyard with
tombstones in the back
honestly um I don't want to see that but
I see it it just pops up it's so cynical
and awful I think it must be perhaps
just muscle memory for him now you know
he doesn't really mean to do it he just
that's the way it works yeah well be
care careful careful what you practice
yes right yeah right right because you
know what's what's first a plan becomes
a habit and then it just becomes second
nature and then you say well I didn't
know it's like yeah you knew once you
just forgot there's one more thing I
want to delve into I think and I think
we should take the time to do it and so
and and then of course I would also like
to ask you what you've learned since you
wrote the book so maybe we'll end with
that but can you briefly relatively
briefly go through the business dealings
that you detail in the book I mean that
takes up like two-thirds of the book I
mean I know we talked about the excess
volume of homemade pornography that's on
the laptop but and I would say that's
relevant in the moral domain but not in
the political
domain there's dealings with China
there's dealings with Russia there's
dealings with Ukraine and that's not all
so do you want to walk through some of
that well just hit the highlights let's
say that's mly there also Kazakhstan
Romania the pattern is always the same
it's uh these these sort of corrupt
countries um they would like to have um
for whatever reason it's either
oligarchs that need uh the sort of Joe
Biden in prata so that they can pressure
their own governments to stop
investigating them um that that's
happened in Romania and in Ukraine uh in
Russia it's more there's an oligarch who
paid money to uh it was sort of I think
it was a money laundering operation I
mean it was like $200 million to um buy
real estate or parts of real estate in
America um and that was through one of
the businesses that actually Devon
Archer was organizing but there was $3
and a half million that seemed to get
skimmed off that and put into an account
of um of Hunter and and Devon uh and so
and it's just sort of you know the
barisma deal they had a couple of China
deals that fell over there was there
always seemed to be uh whenever they
were really with very unsavory people
whenever Hunter was you know mixing with
these unsavory particularly in China um
those people tended to get like arrested
or
disappear and I wondered I I thought
throughout the laptop as I thought about
it there always seemed Hunter seemed to
have a a guardian angel you know he's
Houdini I mean he's still Houdini uh
watching over him and of course it would
make sense people have told me that the
vice president's son would have CIA or
intelligence anyway um keeping an eye on
what he's doing especially when he's a
crack addict um and you know has a
hooker problem um that that they would
be keeping an eye on him and pulling him
out of scrap to save him and we saw that
happening in America God knows what
happened overseas um and one thing I
should say is about Joe's benefiting um
I didn't find a lot on the laptop but um
you know it's like being a little bit
pregnant um and I'm sure there is more
and this is what James comr and the
oversight committee is looking for and
why they're trying to subpoena Joe
Biden's personal bank records and
hunters and the rest of the families um
so I found some evidence that Hunter was
paying for Joe's household bills so um
there was there was uh you know painting
of his um house in Delaware there was
air air conditioning new air
conditioning for a cottage on the estate
um there was a retaining wall um you
know new
shutters why is it why is it so relevant
just out of curiosity um that there is
documented evidence that Joe directly
benefited financially I mean there's
overwhelming evidence that Joe's son who
he travels with benefited overwhelmingly
financially it's like are we supposed to
make the presumption that there's no
moral hazard there for the president
that his that because it's his son and
not him that means it has absolutely
nothing to do with him I mean and yet
this is a very close-knit family that
spend a lot of time together and and
that prayed that around to a substantial
degree I mean I would regard at Le at
least to some degree a favor done for my
son as touching on me in a positive
manner you know I mean I and am I I I
I'm wondering if I've got something
wrong there because of course there's
the legal issue and that's it's not like
that's irrelevant but it would seem to
me that given that it's the presidency
that there's a broader moral hazard
issue here too especially given that
we're at war with Russia because of
because of Ukraine I mean that's not a
little thing the fact that they the
Biden family was Tangled Up in Ukraine
in all sorts of interesting ways let's
put it that way and that we're now at
War and and also an extremely expensive
War I might add where tens of billions
of dollars are being dumped into an
unbelievably corrupt country with like
no virtually no oversight because if you
think there's oversight in Ukraine
there's something wrong with your head
everyone's known forever that that's a
remarkably corrupt country even by
Eastern European standards which is
really saying something and so why is it
that why is it do you think that in
order for there to be a real scand
there has to be absolutely documented
evidence that some of the money that was
definitely paid to Hunter by Foreign
agents had to be funnel directly to Joe
otherwise he's completely innocent we
can just go on as if nothing's happening
that doesn't strike me as reasonable
totally agree I mean it's one of the the
narratives that's being crafted to
protect him and that is you know the
White House has changed from uh Joe
saying you know I knew nothing about my
son's overseas business dealings to um
now they're saying oh Joe wasn't in
business with his son um this was after
Devon Archer uh testified um and Devon
had to be very very careful because he's
facing jail himself and he has a lawyer
pro bono lawyer who's very close with
the bidens so uh he had to be careful in
what he said but what he said was that
the brand was Joe Biden and that Joe was
on the speaker phone with Hunter at
least 20 times when they were having the
meetings uh you know trying to trying to
well if the brand if if the brand wasn't
Joe
Biden then what the hell was the brand
because I don't see any evidence that
Hunter Biden had a brand what the New
York Times And The Washington Post Etc
want is they they're saying oh there has
to be a check with uh Joe's name on it
signed by a corrupt oligarch for anybody
to even open their eyes and say that Joe
did something wrong I mean yeah I don't
think so that that's that's not
something that the people who are
investigating that's not a road that the
people who are investigating this should
walk down the right Road as far as I can
tell is to say hey look folks um we're
in a really dangerous war with Russia
and no one will say we are because we're
all winking and nodding and pretending
that it's Ukraine but it we know what
the hell's going on fundamentally and
there's some chance that part of the
reason that we're in this war is because
things that weren't exactly straight
were going on with the president's son
yeah and you know Victor shoken blames
he blames Joe Biden for some reason
Obama outsourced foreign policy to Joe
Biden no idea why but that's what he did
uh Joe Biden was the guy standing in the
tarmac when XI jingping arrived in
America Joe Biden was the guy who went
to Ukraine you know I don't know seven
or eight times uh and and I mean the
ukrainians even were a bit insulted that
Obama didn't bother ever going to
Ukraine
so so Victor shoken blames Joe Biden the
vice president for Ukraine not being
able to defend itself when Russia
invaded Crimea and of course Russia
invaded Crimea as a direct result in
retaliation for that uh you know alleged
um CIA coup that threw out yanukovich
who was kind of moderately friendly to
the Russians but wasn't kind of in their
pocket um yanuk had been talking about
doing a deal with Europe um which
obviously the Russians didn't like and
he pulled out of and the Russians gave
him a big bribe blah blah blah but but
the fact is that that a lot of
ukrainians Victor shoken being one of
them say that they were told at that
time and poroshenko told shoken this
that the Americans and that means Biden
said look don't do anything we are going
to deal with this diplomatically well
they didn't deal with it diplomatically
I don't know what whether whether I mean
Bob Gates the previous um uh you know
high-ranking Bush and then Obama um
Secretary of Defense said that Joe
Biden's been wrong about every for
foreign policy issue ever and I don't
know whether that's because he's a
bumbling fool or whether it's because
he's compromised in some fashion he
always puts his own interests first and
so uh now we have a situation where
Russia was so demonized and and
completely falsely during the Trump
Administration where the whole Russia
Russia Russia hoax was happening and and
people like Adam Schiff the senior
Democrat head of the intelligence
committee was boldly saying that that
Donald Trump was an agent of Vladimir
Putin he was a Russian agent none of
that was true but it sort of does a job
of demonizing Russia uh in the eyes of
the American people and you know I mean
Russia is completely to BL for having
invaded Ukraine this time but um Putin
would have seen an opportunity because
of course the last time Joe Biden was in
charge of policy for Ukraine uh they
invaded Crimea and nothing happened so
um I I just think it's a very dangerous
situation where you have this this guy
who has to be compromised considering
all the pies that his family was in and
all the millions of dollars that flowed
through to his son and his brother and
various other family members um from all
these different countries that are our
adversaries um you know how can Joe
Biden not be compromised well that's a
good place to
end I would say we're going to do
another half an hour everyone who's
watching and listening on the dailywire
plus platform I'm I don't know exactly
what I'm what I'm going to talk to
Miranda about when we get there but you
can come over there and find out and for
all of you who are watching and
listening you know thank you very much
for that Miranda that's
uh that's quite the book laptop from
hell for those of you again who are
watching listening you might want to go
read that and you know draw your own
conclusions because this is uh it's
something you should be investigating
and thinking about especially because
there's an election upcoming in a you
know about a year and it's going to be
an important one and because things are
quite the mess and they could easily get
worse and you might want to know what
the hell's going on um so let's sum up
well what do we see here well Hunter
left his laptop very carelessly a week
before his father announced his run for
presidency three water loged laptops
just in case one wasn't enough and so
that's three is quite a lot actually and
then a guy who really had no public
exposure at all and no desire for it
coton on to what was on the laptop and
tried to get it to the relevant
authorities and and that was difficult
as it turned out even though he went to
the press and you'd think they'd be all
over it and he finally got juliani
interested and juliani got the New York
Post interested and then that story
broke soon before the previous election
date and then it was shut down and it
was shut down because of fascist
collusion between Facebook Twitter and
the Deep State fundamentally and it was
blamed on Russia collusion and then 51
former security and intelligence
officials wrote a letter stating that
this had all the earmarks of a Russian
disinformation campaign even though
they'd never seen it they didn't
investigate it and that was all a lie
and that was just before the election
which was a which was decided by hair
and after that Trump claimed that the
election was stolen he claimed it at a
level of detail but I don't know what a
sensible person is supposed to think
about the fact that the two biggest
social media empires in the world shut
down the New York Post story devastating
the Biden family on the grounds of the
laptop that Hunter himself left at a
Delaware computer repair shop that's
where we're at all right we'll see
everybody on the daily wire side thank
you very much Miranda much
[Music]
appreciated